[Music]
last time you were chatting a little bit
about how much you love gadgets yes you
do love your gadgets and so I have to
ask you i phone 5 did you get one please
please do you want with me please I got
one you got one yes how quickly did you
get it I didn't line up outside
overnight I have a friend of mine he
does he he helps me do things that when
I'm stuck at work I he said oh my I'll
go out line up
I'll go line up you got something to
line up for you I said I can't have you
go line up overnight and for me for my
ivett without this sleeping bag with
some tic-tacs in a sleeping bag and so
how do you like it you got this thing
yes do you do you have this yes yeah I
do yeah I don't have one so you know
it's well I don't know I haven't really
used mine yet and I haven't decided 3
endorsements to anybody why don't you
tell us what you think of it it's soap
loves me obviously it loves me what are
you talking it we I just it's fast it's
so fast oh my god okay so we have this
supercomputer in our hand and when it's
fast you realize how slow they used to
be it's like yes they could do anything
in the world it'll just just give it a
second wait one more minute it's coming
if I wanted to wait that long for the
answer to a question I'd ask my uncle
Roger who's he's not he's not slow he's
just he's a man who takes his time right
right I want that time back I want now
and now it's be good but don't you find
you get spoiled like I've noticed people
that look at their device and they're
like I'll find out you know how many
melons grow a year in Guatemala and then
they look down and they they punch it in
and they don't get the answer of meaning
they're like piece of crap
and they smash it whoa who does that no
one I just made that up but but still it
does feel like we're growing impatient
we're getting spoiled I you know I used
to this the whole the whole this the
cirrie thing the whole the voice
commands I think I used to have a very
I'm gonna confess a contentious
relationship with Siri she was I and
that partly that's my fault because I
you can have her call her what you
whatever you want
yeah and I had her calling me sport and
it sounded kind of sending after a while
right I'm sorry I'm kind of eating me
alive and I started getting little angry
and but now I've we've kind of like
we've had counseling it's like she's
better I feel better you know you don't
you're getting a relationship with Siri
has improved really has you know let's
end that did the voice text or the voice
email you dictate it like that and I'm
very happy with that and she's not
always super accurate and sometimes
she's way off but I just you know what I
commit to its end whatever she gets it
even if she gets it completely wrong you
say don't care what's the worst that can
happen Siri it's you and me I love you
send it gone sorry I'm gonna be a few
minutes I've been delayed fifteen
minutes I'll meet you at the bar it's
like Oh microwave for 15 minutes who do
you think you are
[Laughter]